[російською] Більшість в'єтнамців виїжджали
до Радянського Союзу працювати на різних заводах.
[російською] І так вийшло, що мої батьки
спочатку працювали на заводах.
[в'єтнамською] Ти щойно прийшов на ринок?
— [в'єтнамською] Привіт. Ми прийшли знімати програму.
— [в'єтнамською] А, так?
[російською] Вони були в різних місцях,
переважно десь у Росії, у Польщі були, під Литвою.
[російською] Власне, там я і народився.
[російською] Ми переїхали, коли мені було кілька місяців.
[російською] І я прожив у Росії,
у Москві кілька місяців і переїхав сюди.
[російською] І весь цей час ми жили тут, тривалий час.
[російською] Можу сказати, що я — щирий українець.
[сміється]
— [в'єтнамською] Вітання!
[в'єтнамською] Привіт, тату! Як справи?
[в'єтнамською] Знімаєте програму?
Тобі дадуть гонорар?
[в'єтнамською] Ні, допомагаю знімати історію
про в'єтнамську діаспору.
[російською] Ми тут давно працюємо.
Ми одні з тих, хто залишилися тут, і працюємо.
[російською] Зараз дуже мало в'єтнамців,
раніше було значно більше.
У дитинстві — так. Багато виходила,
мені подобалось продавати:
«Ой, дивіться, давайте, купляйте у мене! Розпродаж,
оптом, продам у роздріб дешевше, п'ять штук давай!»
Так, звичайно, таке в дитинстві
було, знаєте, як «по фану».
От мама каже: «Продаси мені [щось],
а я тобі п’ять гривень дам на морозиво».
Ото й азарт був піти, попродавати, мамі допомогти.
Зараз, напевно, останній раз я, коли допомагала батькам,
це було десь років сім-вісім тому, може, й більше.
Бо коли я вже почала самостійно заробляти,
я вже туди ні ногою.
Можу сказати, що я завжди користувалась
тим, що я — в’єтнамка.
Там фотограф [каже]: «О, яка в’єтнамка!».
Це трохи незвично.
[російською] Можеш очі ширше відкрити? [сміється]
У кожного з нас є ім’я в’єтнамське — це обов’язкове таке.
Моє ім’я повністю — це Нгуєн Тхай Тхань.
Батьки мене вдома називають Кун,
що означає «цуценя», «маленька собачка».
А нянька в дитинстві мене назвала Лєна.
І мама так: «О, Лєна! Нормас! Нормас, Лєна!
Буде все життя Лєна!» І я от Лєна, Лєна.
♪ [в авто грає в'єтнамська пісня] ♪
[російською] Ця пісня про те, як тато
розповідає синові про його життя,
[російською] з чим він буде стикатися,
над чим йому потрібно працювати.
[російською] В'єтнамці-діти живуть з батьками
все життя, можна так сказати.
[російською] Це повинно так бути, це традиція така.
[російською] Як не крути, завжди
потрібно пам'ятати своїх предків,
[російською] тому що в нас
це теж залежить від нашої релігії.
[російською] Називається культом предків.
[російською] Коли людина, наприклад, помирає,
то її душа завжди залишається біля нас.
[російською] Як тут, наприклад, є розуміння,
що після 18 років ти вступаєш до університету,
[російською] ти сам піклуєшся про своє життя,
все, тепер ти самостійний.
[російською] А у В'єтнамі це не так.
[російською] У В'єтнамі хоч тобі й буде 50 років,
мама все одно буде кликати тебе поїсти.
У в’єтнамців є таке [правило]: неважливо, чи то дівчина,
чи то хлопець — він або вона завжди повинні добре навчатися.
Я навчалася, закінчила [навчання].
Але досі живу з батьками.
Бо для батьків коли ти одна в сім’ї — це одна справа,
а коли ти — дівчина, ти повинна жити
з батьками до тих пір, поки ти не вийдеш заміж.
Ти можеш переїхати тільки
до свого чоловіка жити,
ти не можеш переїхати зараз
до хлопця жити, бо це ненормально.
Вони сприймають це як розбещення,
це як погано вихована дитина.
Тобто ти з батьками доти,
доки в тебе не буде своєї сім’ї.
[російською] Розслабтеся.
Мої батьки з В'єтнаму.
[В Україну] вони прилетіли за часів Радянського Союзу.
Батько прилетів на навчання.
На навчання прилетів.
Його обрали одного серед десяти чи п'ятнадцяти людей,
щоб він полетів сюди на навчання.
Народився я у Вінниці і жив там до трьох років.
Потім я приїхав до Києва.
Тут я виріс і навчався.
Батьки заохочують дітей зустрічатись та
продовжувати своє життя з в'єтнамцями.
Є батьки, які строго до цього ставляться,
а є батьки, які більш лояльні.
У мене були батьки, які щось середнє беруть. [сміється]
Але потім я познайомив Катю з батьками,
і вони сказали, що вона — молодець і дуже гарна.
І вона може бути.
[сміються]
Захотіли побачити В'єтнам з іншого боку.
Останній раз, коли ми там були, то жили там один рік.
Працювали, дивилися, перезимували.
Ми там працювали один рік, сподобалось.
— Сподобалось?
— Мені сподобалось.
Сподобалось там жити, відпочивати,
але працювати трішки було важко,
тому що там якась творча сторона...
Ми хотіли завжди розвиватися в дизайні, у творчості тощо,
а у В'єтнамі це було неможливо.
Загалом, якщо ми їдемо туди працювати,
то це сфера торгівлі, туризму,
тому нам стало нецікаво в якийсь момент,
і ми вирішили повернутися назад,
позайматися тим, чим ми завжди хотіли,
до чого лежить душа.
[російською] Ходімо? У нас ніби до восьмої.
[російською] Так, до восьмої.
Нас четверо, засновників цього бренду.
Наш бренд називається «Мот Бон» — з в’єтнамської
це «один і чотири», що має особливий сенс.
Тобто одна думка, один проєкт, одна ідея,
яка об’єднала чотирьох незалежних, креативних,
талановитих, різних друзів,
і [вони] створили цей один-єдиний продукт.
— [російською] Вітаю!
[спілкуються між собою]
У нашому бренді є чотири засновники.
Це три в’єтнамці — це Женя, я та Міка,
і одна українка — це Катя.
І ми об’єднали всі свої
в’єтнамські й українські думки
та створили цей креативний бренд.
[російською] А є оригінал цього фото?
[російською] Ну так, воно спокійненько.
А тут прямо, ось бачиш?
— [російською] Оливковий.
— [російською] Трішки зеленувато, так?
— [російською] Зеленувато, так.
— [російською] «Вбиваємо» зеленку?
[російською] Так.
Кожен в’єтнамець в Україні,
точніше — у Києві, знає одне одного.
Усі ми десь колись перетиналися на якихось тусовках,
на новорічних святах, де збираються всі.
[російською] Ось сидить на стільчику.
— Е! Е!
— [російською] Як красиво з'являтися!
[російською] Привіт.
— [російською] Як справи?
— [в'єтнамською] Вітаю!
[російською] Ну що, підемо кудись?
Усі батьки наші одне одного знають:
про кожну сім’ю вони знають,
хто там, звідки, яка дитина чия…
Тобто це як маленьке село, в якому кожен
одне одного знає та бачив не один раз.
[російською] Батьки дають нам можливість здобути освіту,
[російською] щоб ми не працювали так важко,
як вони в той час.
Є в'єтнамці, які погано розмовляють
українською,  які пізніше приїхали —
які не тут народилися, а у В'єтнамі,
та приїхали сюди пожити.
Мені здається, їм важче, бо вони більше йдуть
стопами батьків та тих людей, які вже тут були.
Тобто вони працюють на ринку, швидше за все.
А інша молодь, яка вже тут виросла,
працює, як і всі українці.